- Oh hey, Zack, check out this vid.
- Ah, man. Ad.
Skip in five seconds.
Woah!
- Woah!
- What's this ad even for?
- Shh.
- Is this a yogurt commercial?
- I think it's for auto insurance.
- Why is he getting in the car?
- He's getting in the
car to go find Esmeralda.
- Who's that?
- That's the one that's
sleeping with Larry.
- Is that the one with glasses?
- No, that's Dante.
- Dante!
- That dog is literally the
cutest thing I've ever seen.
- Look at the horse, though, it's so cute.
- No, just look at -- (gasp)
- Esmeralda!
(laughing)
- (crying) It's okay.
- Maybe it's an anti-smoking PSA.
- Is this the trailer for a movie?
- Where did the zombies come from?
- Is that the dude from
Friday Night Lights?
- Wow.
- Oh, spectacular.
- Breathtaking, truly.
- Oh, man. Oh.
- [Voiceover] Bonex. Add three
inches to your penis today.
- Oh.
- Uh.
- Oh, hey, here's the actual
video I wanted to show you.
- Oh.
- Yeah. Kittens.
- Ha!